Wir blicken auf die verrückte Reise von Preußen Münster in die 2. Bundesliga und den entfesselt aufspielenden 1. FC Magdeburg und das zusammen mit Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast und Sven Scholz vom Fernsehen 06. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Rasenfunk und zur Ligatur, in diesem Fall der Zweitligaliga-Tour der Männer. Herzlich willkommen und für alle, die mich vielleicht noch nicht kennen oder vielleicht doch schon etwas kennen aus anderen Formaten. Ich stelle mich nochmal vor, mein Name ist Marc Schwitzky, ich bin freier Sportjournalist, vor allen Dingen beim RWB24 zu lesen und bei Hertha Base zu hören. Und wenn ihr die letzte Zweitligasendung mit Eva-Lotta Bohle nicht gehört haben solltet, dann erzähle ich euch diesen Fakt nochmal. Ansonsten müsst ihr es halt nochmal über euch ergehen lassen. Max hat keine Befugnis mehr über dieses Format, das haben Eva und ich gekapert und werden in zukunft zusammen das Zweitligaformat, die Ligatur moderieren im zweiewöchentlichen Wechsel. Letztes Mal hatte Eva, gehört jetzt mich. Also einmal pro Monat dann eine Person von beiden und dementsprechend freue ich mich da sehr darüber, dass wir dieses Format jetzt hier zusammen machen dürfen. Und ich freue mich auch, weil wir in diesem Fall wieder zwei wunderbare Gäste haben. Zum einen Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM-Podcast. Grüß dich, hi!
Ich erinnere mich auf jeden Fall an eine Szene gegen Elbersberg, die er wirklich grandios hält, in der man sehr, sehr schnell nach unten geht.
Schau dir mal alle Spiele an und schau dir mal diese ganzen Szenen an, was dir alles wegfischt. Riesenverstärkung. Wie gesagt, in der Verteidigung haben wir keinen, außer Kier Kessow, auf der rechten Seite haben wir keinen 2. Liga-Profi. Frank Card hat letzte Saison noch 4. Liga bei Bocholt gespielt. Mit Hendrix hast du natürlich einen guten Group gemacht, der war wahrscheinlich günstig, hat auch Erfahrung, aber Batzolli fällt weg, der auch nicht performt hatte. Rovza mit Erfahrung fällt weg. Batzolli war letzte Saison halt eine Riesen-Base, die man im Kader hatte. Wirklich gestattener Defensivspieler. Wir haben überall nachverpflichtet, weil es dann diese Ausfälle gab. Und Friedrichshond ist kein Batman. Also wenn du einen 1,80 Spieler hast, dann der agit ist, der wuselt. Oder du hast einen Friedrichshond, der hohe Bälle halten kann. Wobei uns der, wenn er wirklich performt, wirklich weiterbringen kann, weil die langen Bälle, die wir spielen, dann von ihm auch eben verarbeitet werden können. Und das wäre dann das Konzept. Man muss ja auch von Anfang an spielen, was er jetzt das erste Mal gegen Elbersberg gemacht hat.
Wie ist denn das Saisonziel des FC Preußen Münsters? Glaubt man an den Klassenerhalt oder sagt man, wir gucken einfach, was geht? Wir sind zweimal aufgestiegen. Wir können nicht erwarten, in der Liga zu bleiben. Aber wir dürfen uns jetzt auch nicht auf dem Weg zurück kaputt machen. Wie ist da die Erwartungshaltung im und um den Verein?
Generell willst du die Klasse halten. Aber es ist schon ein Bonus, ein Luxus, wo du gerade stehst. Was du gerade hast, was du als Fan erleben kannst, das weiß auch der Verein. Das Ziel ist natürlich Klassenerhalt. Wenn du einmal an der 2. Bundesliga riechst, ich habe auch irgendwann gepostet über unser Filmmagazin, wir sind gekommen, um zu bleiben. Aber das wird ein riesen, riesen Akt. Das wird schon eine riesen Aufgabe, da die Punkte zu holen. Im Moment stehen wir auch wirklich nicht gut da. Und performenstechnisch sind wir gerade auch nicht auf On-Point. Also da waren wir schon besser in den vorherigen Spielen. Jetzt kommt ein, außer Bronschweig, sage ich jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen, die unten drinstehen, kommen dann wieder die Zickner, mit Düsseldorf, Köln und so weiter. Also Marc Schwitzky kommt auch noch.
Das wird knackig für euch die nächsten Wochen. Also ich glaube, Bronschweig wird wirklich, nochmal so ein richtiges Schlüsselspiel, glaube ich, für euch. Also ich würde sagen, da sind drei Punkte fast schon Pflicht. Wenn man dann guckt, Düsseldorf, Karlsruhe, Köln, Darmstadt, wir, Hertha, da habt ihr jetzt ein paar Wochen vor euch. Ich glaube, das leichter wird es nicht. Genau. Da solltet ihr auf jeden Fall gegen Bronschweig gewinnen. Ich glaube, die nächsten Spiele, dann wird es eher schwierig, glaube ich.
Ja, Bronschweig musst du gewinnen und dann aus den nächsten, weiß nicht, Klitzen spielen, bis Ulln fünf Punkte rausholen und dann gucken, wo du bleibst. Aber das Schöne an der zweiten Liga gerade ist, irgendwie spielen sie alle gegeneinander. Also Darmstadt haut Köln einfach 5-1 weg. Lautern haut Paderborn 3-0 weg. Okay, hätte ich vor dem Spieltag von der Performance, von der Konstellation nicht gedacht. Das führt zu Hause. 4-0 gegen Nürnberg verliert auch nicht. Von daher, ich glaube, es wird für uns eine ganz gute Liga in der 2. Bundesliga diese Saison sein, weil eben die anderen sich die Punkte nehmen. Und das wollen wir, glaube ich, auch nutzen. Aber für uns wird es ein harter Kampf. Jeder Punkt ist… also wenn da nicht Zähne in dem Oberschenkel von dem Gegner stecken, dann haben wir was falsch gemacht.
Ich habe noch so zwei Themen außerhalb des Platzes. Mit durchschnittlich knapp 3000 Auswärtsfahrern belegt Münster den siebten Platz in der 2. Liga aus dem Nichts. Das Heimstadion, auch wenn wir wissen, Umbaumaßnahmen und so weiter, ist trotzdem immer voll. Wie ist es denn dem Verein gelungen, die Fans in den Jahrzehnten, in denen er in der 3., sogar Oberliga teilweise gespielt hat, irgendwie zu halten? Wie ist da diese Identität geblieben? Denn es gibt ja auch genug andere Vereine in der Region. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute da gar nichts zu wählen hätten. Wie glaubst du, ist das irgendwie gelungen?
Das ist dem Verein nicht gelungen. Muss man einfach sagen. Der Erfolg hat es geregelt. Also die Leute, die immer da waren, die waren immer da. Und dann redest du auch vor, ich sag mal vor 20 Jahren so in etwa, gegen Dortmund 2 vor 800 Leuten. Das war damals Preußen Münster. In der Versenkung verschwunden. Und dann ist unter Marc Fascha eben der Aufstieg gelungen. Das hat schon eine erste Euphorie entfacht. Die hat der Verein aber im Marketing technisch, sag ich mal, nicht gut ausgeschlachtet. Konnte er auch nicht, weil er auch nicht die Person hatte, die dafür vielleicht präsentiert werden. Jetzt sind wir ganz anders aufgestellt. Immer noch nicht best of. Also da geht noch einiges. Wir bräuchten noch, glaube ich, drei, vier Leute im Ticketing mehr oder im Merchandising mehr. Aber der Erfolg hat es geregelt. Nicht der Verein. Also wenn sich jemand von dem Verein, was sie in gewisser Weise gut hinstellen, gut machen, gut positionieren, ja. Aber der Erfolg war die Mannschaft. Der Erfolg war der Erfolg. Und das spiegelt sich dann natürlich auch in den Zuschauerzahlen wieder. Aber gehalten? Nein. Da muss man auch so ehrlich sein. Da war so viel, ja, fehlende infrastruktur Schuld, die der Verein nicht hat, jetzt aufgebaut in vielen Dingen. Das läuft aber auch ganz gut. Da wird jetzt on point richtig geackert in Digitalisierung und so weiter. Aber der Verein selber hat nur durch die Mannschaft geschafft, dass genau diese Zuschauerzahlen zustande kommen. Und das war damals auch Marc Fascher. Dass da jemand im Ticket-Ticket sitzt oder jemand im Verein im Medienbereich sitzt oder so was. Dass der Verein da irgendwas gemacht hat. Nein.
Ich finde die Anblicke aber definitiv spannend. Denn von außen hatte ich schon zumindest das Gefühl, dass Preußen Münster lange Regionalliga spielt. Und trotzdem hatte ich immer das Gefühl, dass diese Fanbase präsent ist. Du findest in Deutschland überall Preußen Münster-Sticker. Es gibt nicht bei jedem Regionalligisten ein Fan-Scene, ein Blog, Podcasts, größere Facebook-Gruppen und so weiter. Und das fand ich interessant, dass das durchaus posiert hat weiterhin, trotz der sportlich sehr grauen Jahre von Preußen Münster. Und jetzt, wie gesagt, 3.000 Auswärtsfahrer durchschnittlich ist schon eine Wucht. Und da ist man ja sogar eine Bereicherung für die 2. Bundesliga, was bei so vielen Traditionsvereinen gar nicht selbstverständlich ist. Aber du hast das Thema infrastruktur gerade angesprochen. Das wäre mein letztes Thema gewesen. Das Stadion an der Hammerstraße, die Heimat von Preußen Münster, wird bis 2028 umgebaut und modernisiert. Wir alle sehen ja gerade diese wunderschönen grünen Bände im Stadion, die fast schon was Markantes irgendwie haben. Insgesamt soll das Stadion dann mehr als 19.000 Plätze haben. Was sind denn so die wichtigsten Eckdaten dieses Stadionprojektes, auch wirtschaftlich? Also wie stellt sich der Verein auf? Wie ist da die Stadt involviert?
Also zunächst kann ich dir sogar noch eine positive Nachricht geben, wir werden wahrscheinlich sogar 2027 fertig. Noch mal eine Information. Warum die Westkurve schon abgerissen ist, die wir hätten gut gebrauchen können mit 2.500 Gästeplätzen unüberdacht, wurde abgerissen, weil man nicht wusste, was da drunter ist. Das Stadion ist ja 1926 entstanden und viel Kriegsschutz ist da auch irgendwie noch reingewandelt. Deswegen wurde das frühzeitig abgerissen. Wir werden in der Umbauphase immer so 10.800 Plätze haben, so um die 10.500 bis 11.000 irgendwo, werden es immer dauerhaft sein. Das ist auch wichtig, eben genau um die Auflagen für den DB zu entwickeln. Du musst ja immer was nachhalten. Wir machen ja was und tun was. Die Wirtschaftlichkeit wird sein, du hast jetzt die aktuelle Tribüne. Da sind sieben bis acht Lochen, Sitzplätze, fast 3000 Stück sind es. Das sind die hochwertigen Plätze. Mehr haben wir nicht. Der Rest ist Stehplatz. Was man möchte, ist, auf der Gegenseite dann ein Gegenstück zu entwickeln, wo du mehr Lochen hast für die Anfragen, hochpreisige Plätze, die du vermarken kannst, um auch eben genau die Stehplatzplätze bedienen zu können, dass die Preise auch nicht so explodieren. Was wir auf der Ostseite haben werden, werden dann ein geschlossener Verbund von 8.700 Stehplätzen. Dann machen wir dem Magdeburger ein bisschen Konkurrenz da. Dann wird es nicht mehr so einfach, hier Münster Punkte zu holen. Genau, deswegen, es fängt jetzt mit der Westkurve an. Und dann geht die Gegend gerade los. Aber wie gesagt, in der ganzen Umbauphase sollen es halt über 10.500 Plätze sein. Ich meine, 10.800 waren jetzt so der Punkt, was man dann immer parat haben wird. Und klar, die Vermarktung ist dann halt, die Gegentribüne mit Logen auszustatten, hochpreisige Plätze anzubieten, aber halt mehr Komfort. Wir werden da das erste Standum sein, was das Mindestmaß von 1% an Rolli-Plätzen erfüllen wird. Das ist ganz wichtig. Wir werden sogar eine Kita im Stadion haben. Wir werden die Geschäftsstellen-Plätze am Stadion haben. Wir werden einen Rundumlauf haben, was andere Stadion schon haben. Das ist für uns super. Vom Gästebereich bis zum Heimbereich, weil das auch immer sehr wichtig ist. Weil es in Münster ist es lange Zeit möglich gewesen, mit einem Ticket auf dem Stehplatzbereich von Block M bis zu Block O bis zu Block K zu laufen. Das war früher immer möglich. Und diesen Vibe will man behalten. Der Stadionname soll verkauft werden. Da gibt es gerade noch ein bisschen Diskussionen. Es gab einen Aufruf von der Fanszene. Das kann ich verstehen, aber abwarten. Das ist gerade hochgebrannt.
Und wie läuft es mit der Finanzierung? Preußen Münster wird keine großen Reserven haben. Nämlich an, ist das in Zusammenarbeit mit der Stadt oder dem Land?
Die Stadt zahlt 88 Millionen.
Okay. Und dann?
Der Verein wird dann Miete zahlen. So ist das, glaube ich, so veranschlagt. Okay. Es waren vorher 50 bis 60 Millionen und durch die ganzen geschiegenen baukosten wurde es nochmal aufgestockt. Davor hatte ja der Verein selber gesucht im Umland, also ich sage mal so im Umland 20 Kilometer Umkreis. Und das war erstmal mit Zustimmung und dann gab es aber da im Umland ziemlich viel Teno dagegen. Dann wurde es angestampft und dann hat die Stadt selbst entschieden, okay, jetzt machen wir das hier. Wir sind aber auf maximal 20.000 gedeckelt. Also mehr geht an dem Standort nicht.
Gut, das ist dann die mittel- bis langfristige zukunft. Du hast jetzt kurzfristig nur auf die Saison geguckt, Sven. Was muss passieren, dass du am Ende der Saison, selbst wenn da ein Abstieg stehen sollte, wer weiß. Aber wann würdest du diese Saison als eine schöne, gute, erfolgreiche bezeichnen? Wann tritt da so eine innere Zufriedenheit vielleicht ein?
Also ich bin jetzt 42 und ich habe 1988 in der Jugend von Preußen Münster angefangen. Ich habe 1989 das 2 zu 1 von Preußen Münster gegen Schalke 04, die Leistungsteilung, erlebt auf der Aschebahn. Ich habe einige schöne Erfolge erlebt und ich habe genau dann den Abgang erlebt, von der 2. Liga in die 3., dann in die 4.. Ganz ehrlich, für jeden Preußen-Fan, wenn ich jetzt Hamburg nehme, mit 8.000 Preußen-Fans auswärts mal in einem Stall hinzustehen, die Chance hatten wir nicht. Natürlich sind jetzt viele neue Fans dabei, aber die werden vielleicht auch von Eventi-Fans zu regulären Fans. Aber das war schon so ein Meilenstein, wo ich sagen würde, okay, cool. Dadurch, dass wir ohne infrastruktur, wir haben ja noch niemanden ein richtiges Nachwuchs- Leistungszentrum, was wir ja bieten müssten. Unser Stadion, unsere ganze infrastruktur passt ja auch noch nicht. Das, was wir jetzt mit dem Aufstieg in die 3. Liga geschafft hatten, wo wir schon sehr zufrieden waren, und das, was wir in der 3. Liga dann erleben konnten, mit dem Last-Minute-Aufstieg in die 2. Liga, das kann uns keiner nehmen. Ja, was erwarten wir für die 2. Liga? Ich glaube, da fehlt so ein bisschen Geld für große Transfers, weil du im Grunde genommen von der ganzen infrastruktur, die du ja für die 2. Liga aufbereiten musst, das ist ja Kameratechnik, Torlinientechnik und so weiter, da redest du von 1,4 Millionen. Ja, die werden hier von den TV-Geldern schon wieder abgezogen. Ja, dann ist ja nicht mehr viel, ne? Also von daher ist jeder Punkt ist Kampf, jeder Punkt ist geil und jedes Erlebnis im Stadion, also Nürnberg war es auch geil. Ich freue mich auf Hannover, ich freue mich auch auf Braunschweig nächste Woche, Elvesberg vielleicht nicht, aber Hamburg, Hamburg, Wahnsinn. Also von daher, jeder Preußenfan nimmt das mit. Es wird momentan, es kippt ein bisschen an der Stimmung, das merkt man schon, weil Elvesberg richtig scheiße war, aber davor war es okay und man weiß gar nicht so, wo ist man mit dem Kader, wo kann man dahin kommen, weil immer das System verändert worden ist, die Aufstellung wurde verändert. Schwierig, ist schwierig. Wenn ich einen Badmatt sette, einen Morfzer mit der Erfahrung, mit dem ich schieße einfach an Tore, spielt sie wahrscheinlich anders als eben genau, dass sie jetzt gucken muss, wie Ausfälle zu kompensieren. Es ist schwierig.
Dann kommen wir auf ein konjunktiv zu feststehenden Ding und feststeht ist, dass diese Sendung nun vorbei ist, ein Ende hat. Ich danke euch beiden sehr für die Zeit, Thomas Haufe vom Nuhr, FCM-Podcast und Sven Scholz von 06.de. Vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr mir und den HörerInnen, die eure Vereine näher gebracht habt.
Sehr gerne.
Sehr gerne. Vielen Dank. Schönen Abend.
Und dann sprechen wir vielleicht in ein paar Monaten nochmal, wenn der FCM plötzlich wirklich furios an den Aufstieg mitspielt und Preußen Münster es doch gepackt hat, sich aus den 3., Rängen oder so rauszulassen. Aber das werden wir alles weiter beobachten, da es noch viel Zeit vergehen muss. Aber bis dahin, liebe Grüße an alle, die die Folge gehört haben.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.